in the mid-1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of dr james carse
defined these two types of games finite
games and infinite games
a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football for example there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if
there's a winner then necessarily there
has to be a loser then there are
infinite games infinite games are
defined as known and unknown players
which means new players can join at any
time
the rules are changeable which means
everyone can play however they want and
the objective is to perpetuate the game
to stay in the game as long as possible
turns out we're players in infinite
games every day of our lives there's no
such thing as being number number one in
your marriage you can be number two but
you can't be number one there's no such
thing as winning global politics nobody
wins education you may come in first for
the finite amount of time you're at
school where we have a set time frame
and agreed upon objectives and metrics
but nobody wins education
and there's definitely and there's
definitely no such thing as winning
business
but if we listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't know the game they're
playing in they talk about being number
one or being the best or beating their
competition
based on what
based upon what agreed upon metrics time
frames or objectives and at the end of
the day when we play in an infinite game
with a finite mindset when we play to
win
in a game that has no finish line there
are some very predictable and consistent
outcomes
the big ones include the decline of
trust the decline of cooperation
and the decline of innovation
and if you look at so many organizations
the the rat risk that they put their
people in the finite game which is
everything is about the quarterly or
annual numbers actually over the course
of time destroys morale destroys
relationships and destroys innovation
and the great organizations are the ones
who un are the ones who understand that
the goals and the metrics are waypoints
they help us understand speed and
distance but they're not the purpose of
the game the only true competitor
in an infinite game
is ourselves
that's what it is how do we make our
products better this year than they were
last year how do we make the quality of
our customer service this better this
year than it was last year how do we
make the qualities of our leadership
better this year than they were last
year how do we make the culture stronger
this year than it was last year and this
is the obsession
of the best organizations in the world
they're obsessed without doing
themselves
and by the way the funny coincidence is
they tend to outperform their
competition simultaneously but it's an
obsession with improving themselves
rather than trying to beat their
competition because even if you're ahead
you haven't won anything